talk with a lot of people that you and
think are inspired we do that still a
lot we go to to meet people that we
think are doing such a great job or that
we look up to and then you get so much
energy out of that and I think that can
help you get a long way I'm Emily Tabor
one of the founders of I'm a influencer
marketing agency and Maddie and I'm also
one of the founders of I am a influencer
marketing agency what we do is we create
influencer marketing strategies for all
sorts of brands so we create the
strategy but we also fully execute it so
from influencer matchmaking
the setting up the strategy the full
execution and measurement and reporting
we started working together on a
platform called fashionista comm this
was more of a Pinterest but then for
fashion Maddie was there more from the
influencer side really building up the
influencer network and also the
strategic side of the platform and I was
there more for the commercial end of the
platform really seeing how we can make
it into a business I think because we're
still very young we're a lot of people
in our team are the same age so
sometimes it's hard or it's a challenge
to be part of the team but also be a
leader so to say as a young entrepreneur
to to set up a company and and also be a
yeah be an example for the rest of the
team we launched in 2010 but then we
changed our name and around about 2012
to influencer marketing agency and
that's when a lot of things changed for
us so the market started changing as
well as our to know influencer marketing
and what it would entail so we didn't
have to explain it as much we're
starting to become part of the natural
marketing mix for a lot of friends and
also we built up such a track record
that we could really prove the effect of
influence
marketing of course we want to keep on
growing but we want to keep on
pioneering in this field so you want to
say not necessarily the biggest I think
it's more about the best and the quality
of our work that we want to be be known
off and then next to that we want to
also see what we can do more
[Music]